ich habe es mir gedacht dass er
irgendwas ist ich war aber gerade im
ausland und parallel war eine freundin
irgendwann mir zu hause mit den beiden
kindern weil wir für 21 ausland mussten
und meine mutter war auch da also von
daher war das alles fein das hat sich
eigentlich parallel ergeben dass ich
dachte wenn ich zurückkomme der kommt
nicht mehr zu meinen kindern und das
waren ja auch nur dinge also du wirst ja
auch freunde zu hause habe und sagt mit
kannst du mal kurz auf die jungs auf
beachtliche gehen einkaufen so war das
und er rechnet nicht damit und es ist 80
sind immer aus dem näheren umfeld nach
20 ist ein fremder der dann kommt und
irgendwas tut 80 prozent ist familie
bekannte freunde der nachbarn und die
ich erschleichen sich das mit den
kindern das verhältnis also dass man
sagt nicht wie geht's dir haben
vielleicht ein tier oder wird man die
katze streicheln oder so das wird alles
so spielerisch gemacht die sind ja
teilweise so was von schlau wie das
angehen und deshalb man kann wenn kinder
schützt aber man kann zusehen dass die
fälle und die täter viel schneller als
tageslicht kommt dass man durch und
genau das hat er gemacht du hast
durchgegriffen du bist nicht einfach
alle tage stehen geblieben und was
natürlich war sie schockiert aber du
hast dich davon nicht dominieren lassen
was ich persönlich extrem bewundernswert
finde ich waren roboter und dann hast du
einfach an funktioniert dann
wahrscheinlich hast du ihn ins gefängnis
gebracht
wie macht man ja nicht selbst ins
gefängnis gesteckt wie macht man sowas
welchen weg geht man nicht nur weil ich
finde das ist ein thema
man weiß ja gar nicht richtig was man
machen soll wie verhält man sich richtig
was was macht man was hast du ganz
persönlich du gemacht ich hab mir zugang
zu seinen ja ich hab mir zugang zu
seiner wohnung verschafft er war noch im
ausland und ich habe mir unterlagen
besorgt und hab dann herausgefunden
das muss man sich mal vorstellen er war
elf mal vorbestraft auf bewährung wie
kindesmissbrauch es gibt viel gesang
eines gang ist musste ich gar nicht
natürlich nicht und da fragt man sich
ist das ja mein ex-mann hat damals eine
filmproduktion
über mittag filmproduktion unterwegs
auch im ausland und das war damals der
lebensgefährte von dem filmproduzenten
selber mann ist am set man dreht man
jetzt zusammen man diese familie war ich
habe gekocht für alle
so war das ja also es gab ja noch nicht
mal so dass jeder hat auf die kinder
aufgepasst wer kinder mich überhaupt
nicht springen die dusche oder kann ich
gehe mal kurz zum einkaufen so passiert
ist
und ja ich hab das damit selber alles
raus gefahren ich habe recherchiert das
würde jetzt den rahmen sprengen war sehr
viel arbeit aber ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft druck aufzubauen mit meinem
anwalt ich habe mich mit den behörden
ein bisschen angelegt mit der polizei
und habe gesagt entweder urlaub oder ich
bringe das jetzt sofort an die presse
dass da einer ist der elfmal bewährung
hatte das problem ist dass diese täter
oft auf mitleid machen und sagen sie
sind selber missbraucht worden und das
als schutz für sich nehmen oder als
freifahrtschein oder gegeben ein
teilgeständnis ab das heißt diese zeit
jedoch es tut mir so leid und sondern
sitzt der einer mit einem hemd und einer
brille und der richter sagt oh mein gott
der armen hat es selber erlebt und habe
schon das problem dann geht es mal ganz
schnell auf eine bewährung hinaus hat
[Musik]